hello and welcome to co playing a look
homies let's see below 2,300 again with
this stupid loss oops have to fry now
okay to fight my way back now okay so
this is a pretty nice structure White
has is playing on the diagonal and on
the half-open be far and wide black is
completely ignoring what i'm doing here
must this is really dangerous on the H
file okay so okay and it does not play
you five what's the deal if I take it he
wants to take with the Queen maybe
you'll set the idea maybe I can start
with this move awesome
uh-huh okay he wants to play g5 that's a
good idea action now I should have taken
I should have played it simpler okay so
i'm not going to check later but it's
still pretty nice
I can't think I'm doing this now and
yeah my porn that for actually doing a
pretty good job Wow is 95 now possible
let's see that should win material or to
see have some weird Bishop f5 things
we should have five I have you for me
respect to the seven but he will still
lose material you okay
so always be multiple pieces hanging we
should be five he takes f5 or Bishop d7
I'll take it an e5 Knight and Bishop I
let's see any difference no probably not
d3 maybe it's got 1.4 right right okay I
should have should have allowed c4 I
think you with with hindsight
and visual a form it looks pretty
awkward technically speaking
and I'm going to do the forces and
trading so much
now i'm getting my pieces out now it
wasn't a very good technical play I
think I didn't really um screw it up but
it could have been easy i'm very very
much easier
check black resigns yeah this line is
very comfortable for white with black
taking one c3 and winning a temple here
and yeah H Falls a move that black
should react to just allowing h5 is no
good should play age six or h 5 p.m.
especially not castling I mean this is
getting dangerous really really quickly
and now a queen age 4 is a stupid move I
should take I was thinking okay I can do
it either way but this is just a bit
just a lot better and he will take with
the Queen that what's the idea of Queen
d6 and then we should be four again it
just dies i'm attacking on the e-file
and have the better position on the edge
fire I'm sorry yeah now I this isn't so
clear push you have six yeah he took it
I think this was nice for me maybe he
can do we five with with yeah very
unclear position I mean I lost time with
the Queen going around but I think this
is pretty nice the porn Air Force kind
of helpful and well then then he played
b6 we should lose the game yeah I'm okay
with my play up to this point but I
probably shouldn't allow c4 I mean now
it is winning + 300 still I was feeling
my kids this looks a little bit
artificial this way of winning but it
it's probably okay yeah um if black
plays this line you should normally
prefer to go back to c7
and avoid giving white behalf or can be
found especially in connection with the
year with the c5 being in the bishop on
g2 is very strong there are lines where
black still has the option to put upon
on c6 this is a bit better as you at
least block the diagonal a little bit
okay well thanks for watching